A lot of the games we've been talking
about use consumable in-app purchases.
But there are three main
types of in-app purchases.
Consumables, entitlements,
and subscriptions.
Consumables are items that
get used up in the game.
Sort of like food you consume and
have to keep buying.
Only these are usually power ups that
you have to buy or earn over and
over again.
Entitlements are things that
the player buys and then gets to keep.
Like a sword you get to keep or
level you can permanently unlock.
And finally, subscriptions
are things that the player gets
as long as they keep playing.
Sort of like entitlements,
only you have to renew them over time.
So these are the three main
types of in-app purchases.
Let's look at some
real examples of these.